le drame s'est joué en quelques secondes
seulement hier en fin d'après midi au
lac des prés saint jean à chalon sur
saône
deux enfants de 9 et 10 ans une soeur et
un frère veulent se rafraîchir les pieds
il s'engage alors sur ce rivage où ils
ont l'eau jusqu'aux chevilles mais à
mètres plus loin à peine il tombe à pic
leur frère aîné âgé de 13 ans tente de
leur venir en aide
mais comme eux il ne sait pas nager les
trois enfants sont retrouvés une heure
plus tard par les équipes de secours à
cinq mètres de profondeur dans une eau à
10 degrés pendant près d'une heure des
massages cardiaques leur sont prodigués
devant de nombreuses personnes qui
étaient présentes sur ce lac au moment
des faits le décès des trois jeunes
victimes et finalement constaté à 22h ce
drame laisse le quartier du pré saint
jean et celui des aubépins où vit la
famille dans une peine immense que le
temps aura bien du mal à atténuer